in our building nose knows who I am
because I say hi I opened the door I
help people with their groceries she'll
be in the hall throwing trash away and
if she sees somebody she'll scurry back
to her apartment I started to get to
know my neighbors after I got my dog I
memorized all the dog's names before the
humans yeah cuz they're more important
we were friends before we were neighbors
we didn't we didn't hit it off right
away
did not that's really really a very nice
way to say it I love my family but they
live an hour away and Angela lives for
footsteps away she's my family my life
has been a lot better with her in it
yeah it's true we have coffee together
almost every night if I she wakes up
early enough in the morning maybe like
on Sundays which of us is the better
neighbor no you're the better no it's
not true no I'm just a reflection of you
you can't look at the answer she got me
through my pregnancy I couldn't have
done it without her
she made sure I was eating not just
eating but like eating right I always
need something and heat I'm like I need
to print one piece of paper and he's
like no problem I left it outside your
door she gives you very inspirational
and loving vibes all the time so she is
by far the better neighbor she even went
out and bought non-toxic nail polish and
painted my toenails
she gave me pedicures every two weeks
who is more popular in the neighborhood
wait in the neighborhood yeah me just
because of my dog yes everyone knows him
because I have to carry him he's very
stubborn and so I end up having to carry
him she was like why are you carrying
your dog and I said well it's Hollywood
they get paying for it
you got kids everyone else does
no we leave our doors open
is neater I'm probably neater than her
mmm
Oh what no no there's no way just
because you have in your apartment I've
come to your house and slippers in my
robe
so yeah I've walked around the
neighborhood looking a hot mess you came
over yesterday to borrow borrow cuz he
said you'd give it back
toilet paper I ran out what I say to
someone who doesn't know their neighbors
you're missing out yeah take the time
establish some kind of community you are
definitely missing out on information
important information that could come up
in a true crime documentary you're
missing out on beautiful friendships and
relationships and community
[Laughter]
[Music]